I used to think this kind of [__] was
hilarious and then I realized people are
just got brain problems but here we go
trying to help you
you do you do need my help sir they're
out of CVS or something
can't you see that you son of a [__]
just let me check out my groceries wow
wow this is you got it
crazy I don't have to do anything
no no I'm no I'm not [__] you
[__] accuser get the [__] out of here
you [__] accuser
um you [__] accuser get the
[__] out of here wow you [__]
Chris Farley and the Folgers commercial
dude like
what if I told you it wasn't your
regular coffee and it's [__] Folgers
you [__] accuser
damn
user of the [__] Brethren you
[__] yes ma'am
let me guess man
I'm pissed because he won't repair
oh dude she's in the kids section of a
[__] uh Ross Dress for Less
I just want to get some groceries and go
home
I don't give a [__] because it's been a
brilliant Hill
no taking in no prisoners dude okay so
just because there's religious views
don't uh match with you uh doesn't give
you the right to I don't care
I don't care he's going to hell and you
are too [__]
oh you want your [__]
praise is your savior you're going to be
down there [__] with them
screaming and holy [__] so dutiful
[__] fire and brimstones what's
Brimstone by the way everyone always
says it you know so dude I'm so dutiful
hey [__]
dude I'm trying to save your life
[__]
wow unbelievable a cholo the way she's
talking [__] I'm just trying to help
you yeah poker sorry but I don't need
your help yes you do [__] wow
such a cholo you do you do need my help
sir dude so cholo uh efoker eat
a [__] repent dog a [__] a [__]
pen dog
[__]
in Target just so annoying
[__] pin hey he's going to hell
that's why he's going to hell that's why
you too [__]
where the [__] where the where does
where the toilet paper so hey hey wife
get that [__] hey [__] you're going my
wife ain't going to hell repent [__]
see she just did it hey get grab the
kleenex and then also get the Ring Pops
hey [__]
you got the bread
unbelievable
so like did
that was like trying to be nice but also
adding swear words just don't mix you
know I'm trying to help you don't you
see that you son of a [__]
just let me check out my groceries
I mean the fact that that comes after
that if you're just listening to it hey
[__] hey [__] [__] hey
[__] hey [__] I'm just trying
to help you can't you see that you son
of a [__] ma'am will you just let me
check out my groceries like
dude oh sorry dog that's my b
hey dog
repent dog
one four three dog
or whatever the [__] man
don't you know I'm [__] crazy dog
people are insane holy [__] man oh my
God this lady dude